مطال العربيه يعني معظم ال- اا الطبيعه
الجغرافيه بتاعتها صحراويه
فاعتمدنا على نوعين في الاساس من الطيور
الجارحه هما اللي صار الشاهين واثار الحر
هم يعني اكثر نوعين في طيور الجارحه
مناسبين للظروف البيئيه اللي عندنا
وليد
واسماء من بينها صقر شاهين والوكري والحر
ولكل نوع من الصقور ما كانوا معيشه ووجهته
وتعد مصر واحده من اهم معابر الطيور
المهاجره التي يستغلها الصقارون المصريون
للصيد وبدء ترويض الصقور واستئناسهم كل
طبيعه بتفرض على الهاوي او الصقار استخدام
غير معين
ليه مثلا احنا الطبيعه بتاعتنا الصحراويه
الطبيعه لو في غابات الجماعه في اوروبا
بيستخدمه الباز الباز هو يعني عنده قدره
كبير قوي في المناوره والتحرك بين الاشجار
وبرده الفرائس هناك اكثر همم الارانب
وطاهر
اسيا في فرائس ثانيه اكبر في ثعالب في في
همم قبائل بتاعه منغوليا وكذا بتقول
بيستخدموا العقبان
طويل بين السقاريين فهو الاسرع بين اقراره
فجسده واجنحته القويه تتيح له السفر
لمسافات طويله وسرعه عاليه ونفض شاهين
يعني الملكي بالفارسيه شاهين ما بينزلش
على حاجه تعبانه يعني ممكن يدخل في سرب
حمام بيلاقي في واحده اثنين تعبانين في
الارض
ان ما كانتش الحمامه
طالعه من مكانها بسرعه البرق هي دي اللي
بيركز عليها لانها اعرفها تمتاز بصحه جيده
والصقار مدرب المحترف عليم بكيفيه التعامل
مع الصقور كيف يربيه كيف يصطاد الفريسه
وكيف يقطع المسافات
وللسقاريين لغه خاصه يتداولون مفرداتها
يوميا كالتدهيل والتلوح
بالضبط
[موسيقى]
بتتعامل معك فيها الظروف اللي انت بتضرب
فيها بتتغير
هواء يوم مشمس يوم ايه نوع الفريسه بيتغير
فانت كل ده بتتعلم اساليب جديده في
التدريب هو اساليب كثيره في الصيد معامله
الترس ذات نفسه والعنايه بها دي برده
بتحتاج خبره ترقوميه اا بالنسبه ان انت
هتبقى مبتدا هتاخذ جانب نظري هتتعلم نظري
اعلمك السهر ده ايه الانواع ايه الانواع
المناسبه لك ايه هو الادوات اللي بتستخدم
في الهويه دي يعني انت عشان تبدا اللي هو
دي لازم تكون انت محضر ادوات ومكان اللي
تقدر ان انت تراعيه بتطير وتتحكم فيه انا
عشان اتحكم في الطير ده لازم انا عندي
ادوات لازم عندي الدرس اللي هو الجوانتي
ده اللي انا لابسه ده عشان يحميني من
المخلف بتاعته طبعا هو المخالب
فانت لازم جوانتي من الجلد الطبيعي عشان
يحميك
القيود اللي في رجله دي
دي اسمها الصواريخ الثوابيق المرسل المدور
الحاجات دي كلها الادوات البرقع ده البرقع
ده الانسان اخترع علشان يبدا يتحكم فيه
اللي احنا بنغمي عينيه لكن بنسيبه يقدر
يتنفس ويقدر ياكل برده بس هو مش شايف فهو
لما بيبقى مش شايف بيهدى هو هو عنده حاسه
النظر دي هي ال ال رقم واحد طبعا الصقر
دائما بيتضرب به المثل في قوه البصر